this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday the 21st of february the joint is
presented to you by on it when it comes
to supplements on it is tip top magoo
you know me i love the alpha brain i
love the shroom tech i love the immune i
like i like it all listen they got some
great snacks protein bites go to
honor.com right now
press and code joey and get 10 percent
off
delivered right to your house i can't do
nothing with the kettlebells but
supplements i'm uncle joey supplements
so go to honor.com preston joey the
joint is brought to you by
blue chew
listen to groundhog in your underwear
sword shadow which means there's six
more weeks of snow coming out of your
pants let blue chew throw that dick out
this winter listen blue chew is great
you can take it anytime anywhere it
tastes great and within 30 minutes
you're ready to [__] rock you
understand me slinging dick with three
hands the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com talk to their licensed
medical providers once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part is it's all online no
doctor's office no pharmacy no judgment
it ships right to your door in a
discrete package bluetooth tablets are
made in the us of a way cheaper than any
pharmacy so you can benefit from extra
confidence when it comes time to perform
blue chew can help and they've got a
special deal for the joint listeners try
blue chew free
when you use promo code joey j-o-e-y at
checkout just pay 5 hours for shipping
that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information and i want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring the joint and now without
further ado let's get this party started
joy
[Music]
my
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 21st
of [__] february
[__] is moving quickly on a daily
[__] basis but we're here for another
fun-filled episode of uncle's [__]
joey's joint first off thank you for all
the birthday wishes
it was uh a lot of fun my birthday this
year
you know like when you don't expect
something and [__] happens it's a good
[__] birthday you know what i'm
saying it snowed a little bit
i told my wife that my mom used to
always take these pictures of me on my
birthday
every [__] year from the time i was
you know
two years old walking into the bar like
when i was two obviously she carried me
in
and i remember i had those albums those
albums went from 2
to 13 the last year i did my birthday
party
and the only thing that those albums had
in common was that every year on my
birthday there was [__] snow on the
ground and i told my wife this i go
every year on my birthday you could
guarantee there's snow on the ground
we woke up
saturday morning my wife goes huh you're
[__] up there's no snow on the ground
i go give it a couple hours and sure
enough
like at 10 o'clock it was snowing like
like just you know for a couple minutes
it just went away
but they said it was we were gonna get
hit with uh
something i forget what the [__] a shank
whatever the [__] it is i'm not a
weatherman
they said they were gonna hit us with
some [__] hour or snow
so i figured that was it we went to uh
my daughter's friend had a basketball
game so he went over there with a bunch
of parents and hung out
when i walked out of the basketball game
it was [__] sunny as [__] tip top my
goo cold as [__]
but it was still sunny out
i came home we were gonna go out to
dinner we had to drop my daughter off at
a party let me tell you something
my wife was talking to me about
something i was downstairs i went
upstairs and i go what the [__] happened
to the sun
and i looked out the back door
and guys it looked like [__] colorado
out there
it looked like [__] colorado now i
had plans we had birthday reservations
at a restaurant i couldn't get any
restaurant
i couldn't get any reservations anywhere
and i wanted to go somewhere new i
wanted to [__]
branch out to red bank or [__]
long branch or [__] uh new brunswick
but every restaurant i called had you
know i like to eat early six o'clock 5
30. i like to get out of the way i don't
want to be there at eight because if you
get there at eight the people who sat
down at six
are enjoying themselves and they don't
want to get up now so now you're
standing in the restaurant waiting for
them so i hate all that [__] i hate
waiting so i always get the 5 30 to 6
o'clock table
i caught like 10 [__] places and
every place was packed up
so me and my wife caught i didn't want
to go to el nido again i mean they
[__] live in el nido you know i
haven't been there in a month i haven't
been there the whole month of january in
february it's crazy i haven't been there
since december
so we picked the osteria they said we'll
take you
but i told my wife i go listen what
we'll do we'll go to the osteria but if
it's a nice day
what are we going to do
the kid wasn't home she was [__] at a
at a sleepover party up the corner with
10 other lunatic girls in fact they
would ask sunday to like four in the
afternoon with the mothers having brunch
only in [__] new jersey i went over
there just to bring my wife something
there was 20 [__] parents over there
they had donuts
mimosas bloody mary's they [__] live
it up in jersey so
i was gonna take a ride up north
maybe go to
stop at rudy's or something maybe get
something cuban
you know whenever we go out to dinner we
got the dinner boom and we're home like
[__] old people i like to do
something maybe go for a walk afterward
see the new york skyline once i saw the
snow
all that [__] went out the [__]
window i said [__] it we'll just go lay
osteria and i'm happy i went there
the dude the [__] chef was like
listen the specials tonight are like
my god they got such great [__] food
over there and it's so weird how every
restaurant this area is very good
but different
that's what i really like about donald
you know
so i got the uh
i got a nice little [__] salad
what i get for an appetizer i forget now
it wasn't much because i told my wife
listen i don't have an appetite like i
used to know i could smoke 80 joints
and my appetite isn't what i used to i
go for me to get an appetite i got to
eat a couple abx's and that's what i did
i inhaled three abx's
the 200 milligram [__] it's my
birthday jack i'm gonna cut it up at
least a little bit i'm close to the
house i go let me eat three [__]
abx's
so what'd i open up with that's terrible
and i can't tell you what i opened up
but i opened up with uh
tuscan salad with no [__] cherry
dried cherries
and extra tomatoes and that [__]
you know uncle joey loves his jersey
tomatoes
and then i switched it up i had the
short rib
[__] tremendous with mashed potatoes
i gotta tell you something
the mashed potatoes tasted like [__]
heaven
they tasted like [__] heaven they you
didn't it just went in your mouth like
snow you have snow and it goes in your
mouth and it melts
that's how oh my god it was [__]
delicious
for the dessert i had some fruit with
some cream
i kept it nice and light so when i walk
nothing worse than going to dinner and
walking out of there like you're [__]
pregnant you can't [__] you can't
[__] breathe you're dizzy [__] all
that i wanted to keep it light i hate
half the sharp rib half the mashed
potatoes
guess what else i did last night
for my 59th birthday i had a [__]
tequila i had a margarita and [__] who's
better than uncle joey i had myself a
little jalapeno margarita my [__] was
on fire on the lord's day i couldn't
even every time i thought oh lord i
thought of my [__]
to please have mercy on my [__] that
jalapeno [__] uh margarita destroyed
me but it was perfect and on the way out
the one kid said listen i want to buy
you a shot for your birthday i'm a cuban
dude i said bring it on [__] so he
threw me a shot of lemon jello whatever
the [__] lemoncello i don't [__] know
so uncle joey was in red [__] form
last night but hey
it's your birthday so again
thank you for all the well wishes it was
great i had a great time at the house
listen
like i told you [__] i didn't
move back here to go to studio 54 i just
moved back here to have a normal [__]
life
i went down to austin this week
tremendous
i tell you what though i'm not gonna fly
again until they remove the [__]
the mask i got to be honest with you
through the airport you're not going to
get me to put a mask on i really don't
give a [__] i think one person said
excuse me sir put your mask on and they
winked at me it was jersey they don't
enforce [__]
i walked right through nobody said
nothing to me you know i got to the
[__] plane i got to be honest with
you guys i understand why
people are [__] beating the [__] out
of each other in the air i get it so if
i said any derogatory remarks about you
in the last couple months please forgive
me you know me the bigger the man the
bigger the [__] mistake let me tell
you something those stories is on that
[__] plane got on my last nerve
because they won't stop with the put on
the mask now you guys know me i'm not in
business to get off get banned off a
plane you know i don't want to fly
but i'm also not looking to not being
able to fly it's a big [__]
difference okay it's like you may not
get in your car for a [__] month but
when they you got a dui you can't get in
your [__] car for a month that sucks
remember when you can't do something
that's when you all of a sudden want to
[__] do it that's when people be
calling you from all over the world for
all these exotic jobs and you're like
well i can't fly on united because i
[__] told the stewardess to go [__]
us out
guys you know me i'm a gentleman
i would never disrespect the student
but a stewardess i'm sorry a student i
would never disrespect the stewardess
but jesus christ they didn't say
anything to me i don't give them the
ammunition
to have to come over to me and say sir
put on your mask
this is a warning i was on a flight
where they gave warnings to people
for no reason
you know they tell you and then
here's the [__] thing that pissed me
off okay we gotta wear the mask i
understand that now let's say you got a
gin and tonic again i don't drink gin
and tonics on a [__] plane but if i
did i'm sticking up for the gin and
tonic guy
they don't give you no cocktai tails at
takeoff now
i'm not an alky but i feel for you i'm a
[__] pothead i understand
you know you get on a plane i understand
how the the mind of the drinker works
and i wish i had it i'm not putting you
down or anything there's nothing more
there's nothing
prettier to my eye there's nothing that
makes me more envious of somebody
when they order a seven and seven
a coke a jack on the rocks or whatever i
do not judge you
i enjoy watching you get that drink put
the napkin down
put it down look at it and go
and you could see that whole body just
come to a [__] rest i envy you
i wish i could do that i wish i'd come
home at night take off my [__] shoes
and a [__] seven and seven would take
away all my problems i wish
i [__] when i was a kid i grew up on
watching people do that [__]
so from the age of 14 to [__] 20 i'm
like i can't wait
to have a drink with somebody like
sinatra and just you know
just hang and
talk [__] it looks so [__]
appealing to me
but they can't even do that anymore i
know the people in my area weren't
[__] drinking you have to wait till
you're up in the air to drink
and then they'll tell you on the
loudspeaker 80 [__] times in three
hours
if i didn't hear it
in three hours if i didn't hear it
25 times each plane ride i'm [__]
lying to you people
why you're eating like i ate breakfast
on the way out but i didn't eat anything
on the way back it just looked like it
was the first time the food scared the
[__] out of me the girl next to me got
the chicken with the yellow rice it
smelled so bad
and it looks so bad that's somebody's
[__] a magician is missing a [__]
dove somewhere right now he's got wanted
signs have you seen my dove
that was a [__] dub that poor lady
was eating it was like a chicken breast
on i don't want nobody i try to keep it
simple i don't eat eggs on a plane
they'll give you a [__] headache
those powdered eggs no [__] kill you
those things so
yeah they'll let you eat now but they
keep saying to you
in between bites you have to put up your
mask
in between drinks you have to put up
your mask
and they keep saying it to you while
you're reading remember faa rules
you gotta [__] put on your mask after
the [__] fifth time guys
you feel like banging your [__] head
off the wall and then
she walks around which is her job again
i'm not saying
nothing bad about it
it's her job if that was your job that's
what they're making you do listen go
around the cabin
and tell people [__] until blood comes
out of their eyes
that you got to have a mask up
in between your sips
that is the most [__] ridiculous
thing i've ever heard
especially when there's what a thousand
cases in the hospital in new jersey
right now
thousand cases that's it it's over
and we're mentally over like you could
tell people are [__] over and that's
why for months i've been baffled
on what is all the [__] drama on
these planes the [__] stories to
drive you crazy
and again
if this was me 15 years ago
i would have [__] snapped on that
plane after the eighth you got to put
your mask up in between meals i want you
to listen to what you just said to me
i want you to think about what you just
said to me so after i take a bite of
that [__] rotten chicken you're
giving me i got to put my fork down
while i chew and pick my [__] mask up
and then when i'm ready oh by the way
let's say that dried chicken gets stuck
in my throat now i gotta pull my mask
down again and get a [__] water and
drink that and when i put that water
down i gotta put that mask up now in ten
[__] seconds i gotta pull that mask
up to get another bite of chicken it's
not gonna happen you might as well throw
me off the plane right now i hope you
got some [__] parachutes because i'm
diving out right now with st louis
that's how easy it is and i get it so
i'm not flying again do they [__]
take away the mask thing that's it that
is it that mass three hour and what
about the people go from california to
l.a uh california i'm sorry
to kennedy airport that's six hours and
31 minutes
with a [__] mask on sitting right
there in a plane waiting to go down
because nothing makes you want to
[__] kill yourself more than having a
mascot on a plane and you're also
waiting like you can't wait for this
[__] plane to end
like as soon as i get on the plane i go
what how much time do i go on a plane
and they actually really tell you like
it says we're gonna land in [__] 3 30
and they're like this flight is two
hours and 21 minutes and you're like
where the [__] do i see 2 3 30 there
that that spells me out at 2 30.
so
what the [__] are you talking about 3 30
in the afternoon they always give you
that extra time in class to get bored
stuck on the [__]
on the whatever the [__] you call a
tarmac or
on the way and the guy that picked me up
the uber dude was telling me goes hey
man i gotta be honest
you're very lucky to be in and out of
here
as fast as you are
i go uh he goes usually if you're flying
united and land in newark
it's an hour wait for your luggage
and i was like well you know what
we're gonna get flying a [__]
breather but it was nice to see joe
i did the whole [__] flight in one
day so i took the four hours down
three hours of chit-chatting with him
and then the four-hour flight back i
don't have to tell you how my back feels
from my [__] lower back
to my [__] everything is [__] sore
i was [__] sore i took that plane on
wednesday thursday i felt good
friday i was walking around like the
[__] tin man from the wizard of oz
everything was sore my hamstring my
[__] knees i mean it was all [__]
sore so
i don't i don't recommend flying
anybody two flights in one [__] day
maybe
like if you got to go from san francisco
to vegas or burbank to vegas or
something i recommend those flights but
[__]
anything longer than an hour and i did
one from california last year you
[__] forget i think at 6 00 a.m
got the california 11
and then got back on the plane at seven
o'clock at night that one was no trip to
the [__] that one was horrible and i
was doing my thing back then i was
withdrawing so my heart wouldn't stop
beating
that was [__] god-awful so
if you need to fly
think about it that's all i want to tell
you cuz that's a [__]
rough goddamn mask but seeing joe was
great
the barbecue in austin is [__] off
the hook
i forget where we went after we did the
podcast i went down there with mercy
godfather it was a hit-and-run i got him
out of jersey for the [__] day he
only has wednesdays off so i was like
come on you're coming down with me and i
asked him on the way home where we going
next wednesday chicago i mean where the
[__] we going we gotta go somewhere i
like that [__] just going away on
wednesdays for the day maybe going to
chicago it's a one-hour flight from
jersey
landing you know avoid getting stabbed
in chicago walk around get a hot beef
sandwich maybe go swimming with bob
lalings
and [__] uh
that's it speaking of bob lingas i want
to thank him for sending me
the best birthday present i got this
year check this out
it's an old school double 07 knife i
don't know
if you heard me talk about this
[__] many times this
this [__]
knife is a
like a collector's edition
as as ugly and as plain as this looks
you can't see it in here
but in the grip
it says like rocco
double 07 in this grip right here
this knife's got to be
50 years old
50 [__] years old
this is the knife i bought in the third
grade i used to see this knife all the
time
being advertised in magazines and [__]
and i was like enough is enough
i gotta stab a [__] now that i'm
in the third grade i gotta earn my bones
so i went to a knife shop and like 150th
and broadway
and i think it was 10 bucks back then
9.99 i bought the [__] knife and i
was ready to stab a [__] i'm
walking down broadway with my little one
what what
what the [__] are you talking to say it
again i'll stab you ass and what you did
was you brought this home and you put
like uh you put like dw40 in here so it
could be slippery and then you put dw
40s for like a week you had greasy hands
every time you think the what the knife
out it would fly out of your hands and
[__] you're like hold on let me pick my
knife up from the floor but then it gets
nice it's not a switchblade
so you basically gotta open it a little
bit and go what the [__] are you talking
about [__] you want some of this
you ever seen those old movies in new
york in the 70s they always had a
[__] knife and i wanted a knife so i
actually went i bought it and i was
walking around with this [__]
for a week
i had this [__] like that's when
i used to go to cat no that's when i
used to go up to my godmothers on the
weekends
i had that holiday week off that april
you have that little uh easter weekend
and i went up there and i bought this
[__] and i told my mom i was
staying at my godmother's all week she's
like something don't sound right this
[__] would come to the bar and
torment me
not that week i walked around harlem
flashing they said [__] what
[__] i would go to the movie theaters
what do you mean it's pg-13
i'm walking in this [__]
and one day my in those days my mom used
to do sneak attacks on me which that
means that she would take a cab from
88th street
to [__] uh 148th street and i'd be
playing on the street my buddies
throwing rocks you know chasing some
[__] bum or whatever and also she get
out of the cab and say oh santonio come
here and i'd have to walk up to my mom
and have to wipe my face and she'd go
look at the [__] shape of you you're
dirty your pants are ripped you look
like a [__] what would she call me
mata pero
that means you're out killing dogs all
day get in the [__] house and she
would chase me to my godmother's house
and yell at me in front of my god mother
my godmother will go what the [__] he
doing he's just playing he's a little
boy let him [__] play and get dirty
he's not the most be clean in a
three-piece [__] suit and my mom
would go [__] that and while my aunt my
godmother was talking to me i'd be in
the shower and then when i come out my
mother would already be there with a new
set of [__] clothes she'd go around
the corner to like one of those [__]
uh
boys clothes things and she gave me like
a new pair of [__] white shorts a new
t-shirt brand new sneakers and she go
you got to put this on you got to look
clean i can't have you on the street
looking [__] dirty and i put on this
little half a [__] suit she'd have like a
little sailor [__] shirt and [__] and as
soon as she got in that cab my godmother
would look at me and i go
take this [__] sailor [__] off me
these kids will beat me up up here for
wearing this this is what you wear on
the lowest streets on the upper west
side you can't wear this [__] gi joe
suit to harlem they'll beat you up for
[__] sure i caught a couple [__]
beatings up there as a kid i
like three or four [__] beatings just
to doing the same weird [__]
but once i got that knife nobody was
[__] with uncle joey jack
so my mother [__]
dropped the [__] bomb on me jose
antonio come here so i was cool i had
carpet to pants and that's why you
bought carpet to pants in those days
to put the knife on your side pocket and
[__] and nobody could tell and if
somebody [__] with you then you went for
your little double seven like what
[__]
but my mother goes she's searching my
pockets and how much money you got on
you i don't know a couple dollars and
all of a sudden she went to hit my
pocket and she felt that [__] knife
dog and it was over
she took that knife out of my pocket
she's like what the [__] is this and i'm
like ma it's like a science project
she's like science project my ass that's
a [__] knife
get the [__] to your godmother's house
and when we got to my godmother's house
my godmother tried to protect me but
i she couldn't defend the knife
yeah
he's [__] ate
why has he got a knife no i know he's a
boy
and he needs a knife to cut twigs and
[__] but that's a that's somebody to
kill somebody either he kills somebody
with that knife or he's gonna [__]
fall and cut himself
so my mom [__] took the knife from me
i was pissed i had saved up money and
waited a year to talk myself into going
into a store and buying this [__]
knife and she put me in catholic school
that knife
is the reason why i'm a [__] catholic
[__] prude
because this [__] got me in so
much trouble but i always wanted another
one and i never got a chance to do it
and by the time i realized what was
going on i didn't really want to carry a
knife but the other day i opened up a
bob from i opened up a box from bob
lalingus
and i see this knife and it took a
little it took a little wind out of my
sail like
that was
that was the original [__] you know
before blow this was my [__] weakness
i love knives and stars and [__] i would
buy the [__] stars and they come
unsharpened
oh that sucked because your dick was
hard you're like i'm ready to go [__]
throw a [__] star at somebody
oh my god no they wouldn't even stick in
the wall when i got him i used to get
pissed so i'd take him to a hardware
store and the guy would have to put him
on like a [__]
thing and then [__] sharp and he
would ask you what are you gonna do with
this i don't know
i don't know i'm gonna [__] kill
frogs don't just don't throw the human
beings as soon as he gave you the three
stars you were out there whipping them
at homeless people and bombs and [__]
what a shame i had such a shitty [__]
childhood
it's funny that
we brought up
uh
action park on rogue in the other day
and it's funny that he had never seen it
we when i got there we were outside
talking
and i think somebody said it like hey
man you're from jersey how far were you
from action park
so i started telling stories of one of
rogan's buddies
joe heard part of the story and he go
stop it we got to talk about the show
the podcast what the [__] we forgot what
half the [__] we were saying about
action park if you haven't watched that
you saw it right mike when it first came
out i think you're the one that told me
about it
to watch action part
you know
i always said that bothers me a lot that
my daughter is not going to have the
same child that i had now look i don't
want my daughter stealing i don't want
my daughter
hitting people in the light bulb from
people in the head with light bulbs from
[__] and whatever there's a thousand
things i don't want from my daughter
she's a little girl
you know last uh two nights ago when we
went to eat at the osteria
a mom came in and she sat next to us and
she's like i don't want to embarrass you
but my son's a big fan you know and we
started talking
she was very nice
very attractive mom italian from jersey
city
and i go you know what made you move
down here and she goes listen
when you're in jersey city it's great
for kids it's great
it was great for me to grow up there
she goes you become hip to the street
you become very street smart you see it
coming
she goes when i move my children down
here she goes i always wanted my
children
to be street smart
but
she goes to street smart today is a
little different
so when
they were about eight i moved them down
to central new jersey
and she goes yeah we give up
a little bit on the street smart but
it's a better
they grow up better they grow up
they get up hidden from that street
smart [__]
but the quality of growing up is better
they're always busy
they don't have to [__] get on a
tunnel they don't have to get on a
[__] train to go have fun
you know growing up up there you know
the city is a stone's rock for me
so it's very hard for me to tell my son
mike don't go to the city you know after
a while you're gonna go [__] you there's
something over there and i'm not saying
that my daughter's not gonna get on a
[__] bus
and go to the city right from the corner
here on route 9. they got buses that
take every 10 minutes into the city and
to other parts of jersey so don't expect
me one day to be pulling my [__]
hands out because my daughter told me
she was gonna go to a museum in long
branch and they got into a bus into the
city you know what
every kid does that and if i get pissed
off at her for that
i'm being a [__] hypocrite because
every kid does that you're [__]
you're 35 minutes away
from the american metropolis
remember if new york catches a cold
the rest of the country [__] sneezes
it's just that [__] simple and that's
the way it's always [__] meant so
it's tough to talk a kid out of going
into [__] new york and jumping up and
down and getting [__] uh stabbed at
that so this is my thing this is what i
always thought i always thought that
they
had those places like action park
and there was another place i used to go
to tuxedo new york
there were there was the quarry there
was like five or six places
that we had in the greater new jersey
new york area
that you piled in a car when one of your
friends became 17 and your father or
grandfather gave them that station wagon
the they had the the family edition the
country edition
years ago chrysler chrysler dodge
dodge sold the uh
the minivan but they had a minivan that
was called the country
whatever package and that's got the
extra seat
that's got the air conditioner in the
back you know when we were like when we
were kids you had no [__] air in the
back
so every weekend a kid died in jersey
from being in the [__] in the third
row seat back though there was no air
that poor kids back there yelling help
help i can't [__] breathe there's ten
kids in the car they don't give a [__]
they're like what's wrong with your
brother oh you can't breathe [__] him
we're over here playing tic-tac-toe
listening to 10cc i'm not in love so
don't forget so if you were in the back
seat every two weeks a kid died when i
was growing up kids died all the [__]
time think about it
oh my god oh kids died all the [__]
time you think i'm [__] kidding you
when the first i'd listen i could lie to
you guys and tell you i was going to
uh
action park when i was eight no i went
to action park later we were kids in the
northern new jersey area
our [__] place our go-go two place
was palisade [__] amusement park did
you ever get to go to palisades i had
the picture here i had it somewhere
is that oh yeah yeah power state
amusement park palace said amusement
park was on uh was in fort lee cliffside
up there
and it was by the rocks where
picalissimo was and all those
restaurants i talked about
and it had a
a pool that was a real wave pool
all right
if i close my eyes the only thing i can
remember from palisade amusement park is
how [__] good that vanilla ice cream
cone was holy [__]
holy [__] the vanilla ice cream cone at
palisade amusement park was [__]
tremendous do you understand me and i
remember the wave pool and [__] and then
that closed when i was like six pal said
amusement park closed down they built
condos on that's the first time we got
zapped by [__] politicians as a kid
we didn't even know it what happened to
the plastic amusement park they're
closed they're building condos i'm sorry
to interrupt but the joint is sponsored
by better help online therapy listen
relationships take work a lot of us will
drop anything to go help somebody we
care about we'll go out of our way to
treat somebody else well but how often
do we give ourselves the same treatment
i invest in myself every monday morning
with my therapy this month better help
online therapy wants to remind you to
take care of your most important
relationship
the one you have with yourself i can't
tell you the gains
i've made since i've been working with
dana at betterhelp.com
i'm uh
anxiety free and it's just great talking
to that person that's outside of the
loop
every day every week
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for your haircut or even trying therapy
you are your greatest asset always
remember that so invest the time and
effort into yourself like you do with
other people better help is online
therapy office video phone and even lot
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in person therapy
and you could be matched up with a
therapist in 48 hours that's it give it
a try and see why over 2 million people
have used better health online therapy
including your uncle joey now the joint
is sponsored by betterhelp and listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
diaz d-i-a-z that's betterhelp.com
diaz
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash diaz that's better help go
take care of yourself and now
back to the joint
the only reason why i didn't get mad at
those condos is because jackie gleason
moved in there years later so whenever
you drove by you go that's what pallas
head amusement park used to be those
[__] put up condos yeah but
jackie gleason lives in those
[__] so you kind of gave him a
[__] pass
and then it was a [__] six flags was
in jackson new jersey
i didn't really go to six flags
until i was
maybe 17 i came down here
but when i was 11
when i didn't live at home those years
when i was like in the sixth grade and i
was scared to be in my house because
there were spirits in my house i lived
with a family the torrez family the
bookmaking family i stayed with their
youngest son
when i was a kid see guys i got hustles
coming at you from all over you could
never say nothing bad about uncle joy
that hate and hustle because it was in
my [__] blood
when i was in the sixth grade
i had a scam going on that i never even
talked about i didn't [__] even
remember till i moved back to jersey the
area where i moved into was a big scam
area for stolen [__]
english town uh the the [__]
the flea market and english town where
the [__] cars used to race
the the [__] go-kart races and all
that [__] we grew up on them but i used
to come down here like in the sixth
grade to buy stolen sneakers
at the english town auction i used to
get limousines for their feet
which are converse sneakers the julia
serving sneakers they're the ones that
only come in one [__] cut they're
high sneakers with a star on the side
and the converse [__] whoop
this was the [__] neighborhood to
come englishtown new jersey right by
[__]
brooklyn uh south that pizza joint where
they make the upside down [__]
sicilian tremendous
right across from there is the english
town [__] mall
but
we started going there but there was
another place down here that we used to
[__] go to
to
i used to come down here with jose
torres to maguire air force base
there's an air force base down here and
it's next to the town next to jackson or
it could be jackson
you correct me on twitter if you notice
but he had a scam going on in there he
would buy cigarettes in there and they
were untaxed
so you could save like five bucks in the
70s
it's like going to delaware so i started
taking orders at my mother's bar
and on sundays i would go down with him
and i would wait for him to go in and do
his cigarette shopping and then i would
go let me borrow your pass
why because i want to go in there and
buy something and i would [__] go in
there and get 10 cases of cigarettes
myself they didn't give a [__] how old
you were they didn't ask you for id and
then i get like 15 cases 10 cases 5
profit i'd make 75 bucks on the [__]
saturday and he didn't even know it i'd
get on the we used to take the bus down
there was like a city bus that took you
down to [__] uh mcguire air force
base and back and that had to be the
sixth grade me and jose torres
on [__] saturdays then me or me and
frankie balzano on sundays came down
here and we'll get the [__] sneakers
i've always been a [__] savage like
that but when i moved to north bergen
every [__] weekend these
[__] went somewhere
they would either go to like
there was a place in tuxedo new york we
used to go to
and
i'll never forget one time i went there
and i was [__] high as [__]
i was hanging out with my boy lefty
cortina they gotta turn me onto weed in
the beginning i knew about weed
he just made it easier for me to smoke
i went with lefty to the city we went to
cop something
and we got really [__] high and i
ended up going to this pool in tuxedo
new york if anybody remembers the name
of that pool please
send me the message on twitter or
whatever
this place was huge mike
huge it looked like action park
but it was a lot less complicated it was
just a long
pool not olympic pool i like to tell you
it was an olympic pool no it was just
these white dudes whoever built it said
just built the biggest pool in the world
and they put diving boards all over and
[__] and
you know when you get there as a kid
it's great you you go up there with a
[__] uh
the town used to take us up there at
first you know you take your little
towel with the bikini in the middle and
like your mom would give you a buck for
that orange drink and [__] and the town
will give you like a brown bag county
jail lunch and we would go up there for
the day and that was all great but then
as i started getting older you know you
start smoking one joint you start
smoking two joints you start smoking
three joints and then you start going up
there jumping in the [__] pool and
going nuts up there and i remember the
summer summer of 79
when i was already done with action park
and i had already got my experiences
with the quarry
and all these other places around new
jersey the famous that you go to on the
weekends
i went up to the tuxedo in new york like
four of us one in the car
and on the way up dog we kept [__]
puffing
one joint after the other look look at
this is more than i had ever smoked in
my life
at that time in my life i was one of
those like mike
this saturday we're going to buy a
nickel bag and we're going to get seven
joints and we'll smoke one of them and
we'll save six of them for the black
sabbath content you're like okay that
sounds like who's gonna hold the six
joints i don't trust you joey well i'll
give you three and you give me three and
then we'll even then you show up in the
concert night with three little skinny
joints and what the [__] you smoked them
i had to
but
i'll never forget that we went up there
and we [__] bought like a nickel bag
or something
and we smoked every [__] joint in
that bag
and then we got up there and it was hot
out it's humid it's [__] 90 [__]
degrees you know
and we started playing like tag and
two-hand touch football we're trying to
be [__] cute
we're playing two-hand touch football
whatever and after the game
guys i was used to being out there was
no computers in my house
we [__] grew up under the sun you
know we were tougher [__] kids
than today but not really
and uh
i went to get a soda at the hot dog
stand you know like they have like a
little
outdoor stand they have like hamburgers
and hot dogs and [__]
and i walk over there like nothing
happened i uh
got online
you know how they have those bars
where to navigate here now like when you
go to airports they have that [__] to
make you walk crooked
they already had that in 79 over there
and it was pretty much bars you know
like they looked like gymnast bars
there were just two bars next to each
other
and you walked up and back you know so
it was no no big [__] deal
so i was hanging out
on the [__] thing i've never told
anybody this [__] i'm hanging out on
this thing waiting to get my soda
there's got to be 20 [__] people in
front of me
and i'll never forget
that it started like the sun was right
on you it's four in the afternoon
you're right there if it was 90 degrees
now it's 95 the sun's burning at you and
i'll never forget that something made me
touch the railing
and i go i'm going ah it's [__] hot
and then i remember the sun kind of hit
me a little bit like
i heard like birds and i grabbed onto
the railing no matter how hot it was and
my right side went out like i just
fainted in the sun
and i did one of those loop-de-loops on
the bar and just landed on my back
and doug i had [__] people
i had people standing around me
you know i woke up to like 20 people
[__] in a circle like
looking at me and they're like sir are
you okay hey man are you okay hey hey
north bergen because i must have enough
burgers [__] on i'll never forget them
[__]
shaking me shaking me shaking me and me
like
waking up and i'm going are you all
right sir
i'm like hey yeah i'm all right and i
went to get up and i went to touch my
head and guys i had a three inch bump
coming out of my head that when i
touched i went ah and like do you want
us to call an ambulance on my ambulance
not in a million [__] years you know
[__] you
and i remember walking it was expensive
plus i would have to call my mother
and tell her why i was in a pool up in
new york state without her [__]
permission i was supposed to be down the
corner at the balzano's house you know i
was one of those [__] that yeah
we're going to the corner meanwhile
we're 80 miles away you know and i knew
she was gonna come call up for me it was
sunday i knew she was probably gonna
leave to go to the track at two you know
whatever
so i'll never forget them [__] waking
me up and going mr sir whatever hey kid
you [__] you okay and i'm like yeah
what happened to like i don't know
you passed out and i'm like i passed out
and i'm gonna i want to get up i touched
my head it was like oh like i just spun
around and landed on my head thank god i
didn't break my [__] head
and i remember walking back to my little
towel with my friends and i'm like where
the [__] you been i'm like man i [__]
fainted
we got to get out of here like jesus
christ it is getting hot but that was
like one of the least things that
happened to me
but every weekend we would go to a
different place and like i've said
before no disrespect to anybody
one of my dear friends they all went
swimming
and
he [__] drowned and like a pack on
the quarry whatever it was god rested so
either way
dominic i loved him with all my heart i
still remember him every sunday and like
i said to you i wish i was telling you
it was a joke
no when i moved here
one of the first weeks i moved i moved
to jersey august 19th
and i moved into this house september
2nd
so like september 2nd was maybe a monday
or something like that
i think september 3rd
i actually took my daughter around the
block to jimmy jimmy goes come over
the kids are out it's a nice day
you know my daughter had never been out
of la she had never
played in l.a on the street and if she
did it was just for two minutes you know
now
she gets out of the car i introduce the
you know
jimmy son who i love to death and then
there's a bunch of other kids playing
and you know she gets introduced and
they're playing with the ball and all
this [__] the normal jersey [__] that
she's never done i was really happy in a
way
but i remember jim going come in let
them play outside and i'm going out
there i was worried i kept checking on
the checking on the check and i i don't
know
you know this whole new jersey parent
thing is new to me
so finally uh
they're out there till 6 30 at night
and then the the mothers come on and ask
the kids to
go in for dinner and i went and got a
pizza at carlos
and i brought it to jimmy's and luke and
we all ate
and i'll never forget that i was ready
to take her home and luke goes no
the kids are coming back up the block it
had to be seven o'clock at night i had
mercy out of the house since three
now in la i would take her out but for
an hour and a half i would never decide
a mother kept texting me joey where are
you
joey dinner's set and i'm like they're
eating dinner here
you know they're playing we'll get home
when we get home she had school next day
and i'll never forget that it was dark
out
and i go jimmy i gotta get this girl out
of here she's not used to this [__]
and i remember walking up to the street
and going where's my daughter
and looking in the middle of the street
first of all jimmy street has no light
on it maybe one light for the whole
[__] street and it's like a mile deep
and it's all downhill i look up
and there's
every little boy in that neighborhood on
a shopping cart
they're all standing around it and
there's three girls in our shopping cart
and one of those girls is my [__]
daughter and i'm like oh no and the
other girl is really cute and
she's got on like a you know a girl's
dress and i had no idea but she had on
like cleopatra shoes you know like the
boots that you strap up the sandals and
i'm like that girl's gonna lose her toe
and i'll never forget looking at him
going mercy be careful and them going
down the block it was like an episode
little rascals when they stole the
[__] cart with the mule and they had
a boxing glove next to it every time
they pulled up in a light they would hit
the button with the boxing glove and
what was waiting for the bus would get
punched in the face it reminded me of
that [__] cart of them going down the
hill and they weren't doing they were
doing like 15 miles an hour and they
were all screaming and [__] and i'm like
holy [__]
it all comes back to me now now this is
why i know
that kids are so [__] up today this is
why kids are behind the eight ball
it's not that kids don't want to have
fun or not that kids aren't athletic or
anything like that it's that they they
got raised under a different
a different circumstances kids today
my daughter who's nine as much as i've
tried to break this she runs around with
a [__] phone at hand does could she
make any phone calls out of that phone
not even if she wanted to unless she's
[__] uh
what to do who invented alexander graham
bell she's not gonna figure out how to
make a call out of that [__] phone
trust me she ain't that [__] smart
but she runs around with a phone in that
[__] hand i'm trying to break that
habit for them but that's how kids are
growing up today when my daughter goes
to a restaurant and we have other kids
we got to take their phones away
and these kids have phones not to dial
numbers or anything like that they're
too young they have
phones to play games on my daughter
can't live without the [__] so now she's
not allowed to have it the whole week
only on weekends during the [__] like
i told my wife this has to end with this
phone
this is why these kids never get to
[__] play or live like we did it's
not that parents are different it's not
that kids are different kids still come
out of a [__] snatch like any other
[__] kid kids are born it's like you
could [__] uh what's that [__] when
you mimic when you you i don't know
clone kids and [__] now
kids are the same that they've always
been
we just don't push them to do what we
did as kids because maybe we're [__]
scared or whatever
but i'll never forget her going down
that [__] hill with me going
holy [__] i just got it
when i was a kid i didn't go out to
[__] play like we didn't go out to
play marlboros we didn't go out the
[__]
you know yeah we played like uh
hot peas and butter go get your mother
and buck buck and [__] like that yeah
they were little games we played but we
didn't play for that we played for keeps
we didn't go out to play and jump up and
down and scare each other
we went out to die i never thought about
that till that [__] night
that's the difference between the kids
today and the kids 30 40 years ago when
i was out there
the kids i hung out with we went out
there to [__] die i've told you
stories of us [__]
robbing trains i told you stories of us
getting chased
by chinese people at willy young's
chinese palace and will he used chinese
palace and the wing phone these are all
dangerous [__] things i told you
us [__] robbing the chinese delivery
dude and [__] delivering the chinese
food
this is [__] you get shot for
but we didn't give a [__]
we didn't go out to be conservative or
not to hurt somebody's feelings it
wasn't that we were bad kids
the focuses
underline the word kids
what are kids supposed to do they're
supposed to have fun they're not
supposed to know about the problems of
the world they're not supposed to know
about [__] politics not supposed to
know about anything when i was eight i
didn't know about anything and i didn't
want to know about anything i knew about
like you know dumb [__] i had heard of
watergate i knew the president was
[__] nixon but it's not like i was at
the basketball courts with kids going
what do you think of our political
system [__] you we were chasing mr
martini we were killing rats we were
running down a [__] uh you know
uh riverside drive and [__] you know
getting into trouble and that's what
kids do i can't get mad at my daughter
you want me to get a man in my heart
what kind of [__] dad would i be what
kind of
what kind of [__] i hate being a
hypocrite
one thing about me is i [__] hate
being hypocritical and trust me at times
i find myself there with little things
not things that matter
you know the person you were 20 years
ago isn't the person you are today the
person you were 40 years ago isn't the
person you are today so you're going to
find yourself in hypocritical situations
but
as a dad i got to be honest with you
she's [__] nine what do you want me
to do the teacher to be a [__] nun
now no
i'm in business for her to have a great
time that's why i got on that plane
that's why i moved my family from one
coast to another what she's doing what
she did yesterday sunday
she wouldn't be doing that in california
a [__] sleepo with 10 kids 10 girls
with 10 [__] girls
and then
to make things [__] worse
on
sunday morning like we had to sleep over
yeah we got breakfast for them and we
had a couple things but we didn't have
no [__] party for the adults
when i went over there on sunday just to
drop it on them and say hello
there was
all the kids we hang out with like the
little boys that we go to their games
they were there their parents were there
they were eating they were happy you
know i didn't ever had that in l.a and
if we had that it's because the
celebrity was going to be there don't
miss sunday lawrence fishburne will be
there who the [__] gives the [__]
who gives a [__] if laurence fishburne
will be that's the whole thing about l.a
nobody could just have a party everybody
had to have a party and your lure was
for me to have somebody famous there so
you could come and bring your [__]
stupid script or show them your [__]
stupid picture tell them your stupid
[__] story and you know it's not
gonna work out for you that
isn't the case here we hang out with
other people because we [__] dig them
there's nobody that's gonna be there
that could change your [__] life
that's [__]
so
the life she's living here
is f and that's what i told you people
kids didn't go out to [__] play
now they do
these kids
listen i used to call them half a
fruitcakes and [__]
it's not their fault
it's guys like my fault i want my
daughter to play do you think i want my
daughter robin trains
do you really think that do you think i
want my daughter knocking on doors
and telling people she's selling
stickers for the cyl meanwhile she's
pocketing the money you don't need that
in your life yes it would be kind of
cute
but i don't need that from my [__]
daughter i don't i don't even think it's
cute it's something we did that we sold
cyo stickers that were [__] hot and
all that [__] and listen
i had a fabulous time
and
you know
i would want all that [__] for my
daughter
without the criminal element and there
you go joey you're being hypocritical
yes i am i don't want my daughter to end
up in prison like i did i don't want my
daughter to even have
those type of [__] thoughts i wanted
to have individual thoughts
so
when i made that statement it's a
[__] funny joke but here's the funny
thing about that joke
i'm not lying
we didn't go up to you know
i still remember that kid valentine
pharaoh building a ramp on my [__]
block going downhill
that i'm having to pull him aside and go
valentin you're not doing this on this
block
because you're going to [__] end up
with a broken neck and him looking at me
going i don't give a [__]
i'm doing this he was one of those dudes
valentine furrow was the kid i used to
always
give my bicycles to and he'd [__]
crash and fall i swear to god man that's
the first dude
say what the [__] you want my my good
friend john salami is a big bmx adam
john salami is a big beer mexican out of
new jersey out of this area right here
old bridge he loves this when i told him
i was in this area he was going nuts
i got to be honest to you i think
valentine pharaoh in the 70s
was one of the first kids
that i saw this [__] build one
of those ramps like the hot wheels
that you actually jumped off and then
landed on another one
and that that's that's what everybody
did and that's fine i think i even did
it a couple times it scared the [__] out
of me it wasn't for me when you land
like everything turns around and [__]
you gotta like balance yourself that
ain't for uncle joey i was never [__]
i was never one of those dude that's
gonna walk a tightrope but
uh
fernie also
i also saw fernie not ferny
valentine pharaoh god
i hope he's doing well he's a dentist
but i also saw valentine build a ramp
one time
that was for him to spin around
and he didn't do it on the street we
went to the soccer field
because i still remember him dragging it
up the [__] woods and me going bro
what the [__] are you doing you're
[__] nuts him dragging like this he
would build it in front of his house him
and this kid gave michael clements that
had fleas when we were kids nice kid but
he had piojos
and him michael clemons was also one of
those bicycle dead devil nerds
i saw the both of these [__] go
up there and build one of those
things that they wanted to flip the
bicycle over and they did it on the on
the soccer field so they wouldn't get
hurt thank god for that but i think they
did it twice and they're like now we
don't know how to do this you had to go
like the professional park like down
here where it was a little bigger for
bmx riding where they looped the looped
and [__]
but all those [__] were scary
as [__] growing up and even like i was
never a dead devil i didn't i didn't
need to be a dead double i was i was a
walking dead devil i still remember
being in the seventh grade and walking
up to carvel on 38th street
on bergen lion avenue it used to be next
to the bottom of the barrel this mafia
restaurant and it used to be below this
aikido school it was called no kung fu
school
and i still remember walking up there
being like a dumb kid
like in the [__] seventh grade the
first time because you guys know i got
left back in the second grade so it's
second grade i got a lot of chapters in
my life i got second grade third grade
no
seventh grade first time second grade
second time and i got before the
kidnapping and after the kidnapping so
when you see those and you hear those
words always keep that in mind
that that's what's going on with uncle
joey but
what are we talking about i don't even
[__] know anymore who gives a [__]
well it's
so
yeah like when i was in the seventh and
eighth grade i was part of that little
dead devil crew for a while but then it
wasn't for me i'm gonna i'm good at
jumping into pools and [__] i would jump
off like a like uh
yeah oh yeah i was the king of the
diving board but i'm also into jumping
off like i could do one of those things
from almost famous
where he calls himself a god a golden
god and he jumps off the roof into the
pool i did that all the time because
uh we used to go to like laker pacquiao
and we used to go to somewhere else the
quarry the quarry had that where you
could jump and i
and i got to tell you guys something
that
i think in the eighth grade
there was uh one sunday when we went
somewhere
and i took a hit acid with this dude
vinnie lynch that was older than me and
i was drinking heinekens and [__] i went
home
and i was so [__] drunk that i puked
on myself but when i woke up there was a
piece of gum and i always talk about the
story i have i had a great eight-track
player at the time
and i had dark side of the moon on a
track
but
i'm not trying to
make this seem weird
but my friend dominic died
and i heard about it you know he he
drowned on a sunday
and when he drowned i still remember him
going to there and asking me if i wanted
to go and at that time
my mom had already died it was the
summer of 1980. i wasn't living in my
house but i still lived in a
neighborhood around the corner and i
would still see those guys those guys
are still my friends
i was a little bit more spread out when
my mother died i would go uptown and
stuff
but i still hung out with those guys and
one of the reasons why i didn't go with
him that day was because i always knew i
went to one of those little sunday
parties
at the quarry we had to get in the car
and get cases of beer and drive out
there and then people get [__] up and
people go swimming or some guy would
climb a wall it was always something
dead devilish
and i remember after one of those trips
i was like you know what
i'm not going on these anymore
because i want something's gonna happen
like somebody's gonna fall
somebody's i never thought of that i
would love to tell you that i knew
somebody was gonna die no
i just knew that
there was too many of us
you know would be 16 17 kids
couple girls
and we would play buck buck we would
play [__] like that but you know the
diving and stuff and jumping and all
that
when you add alcohol to it and you add
[__] drugs to it
something's gonna happen like somebody's
gonna slip and fall or something so
i never thought it would be one of my
close friends so when they came back
that sunday and told me he drowned and
they had to look for the body all night
i was like that's the last time
that was when i ended my [__] games
of going out to die
because now i knew it was [__]
possible
you know i didn't say this joke as a
[__] joke i meant this
as real
when i was growing up
the level of play i mean guys i almost
died twice the night that new jersey won
the state championship
i took a hit a really strong acid that i
should have never taken
and i was walking the streets one night
and dog till this day i remember
a [__] car coming at me and i was so
high on the asset that i just was like
look at the [__] car coming at me and
he must have been drinking or whatever
because he didn't slow down if it wasn't
for a friend of mine
pushing me out of the way we wouldn't be
having this [__] podcast right now
you know i remember like stupid things i
looked at myself and go wow one night i
went over to joe lucci's house it was
his birthday this week
my birthday is the 19th his is like the
14th to the 15th i sent them a merry
christmas uh happy birthday on facebook
but joe lucci i went to his party once
we were gonna go to a [__] concert
and i started eating quaaludes and doing
bumps and drinking it wasn't even the
sun was still out
and i remember that
i remember waking up sunday morning
having puke all over me
and everybody around me was passed out i
remember sitting there for an hour
thinking
what the [__]
happened last night
and i couldn't [__] remember what the
[__] happened
and i remember just getting up and
sneaking out of there and getting home
that's when i was staying with the
benders
and somebody calling me saying are you
okay
[__] we thought you died last night we
thought you
oh deed
you know i don't remember anything they
told me my [__] eyes were pinned in
the back of my [__] head
and that
had no color to me and that [__] you
know it didn't look good for a minute
but that was the joe lucci crew
if you passed out or something you were
on your own you were saying it wasn't
like they were going to put our towels
on you it wasn't one of these comforting
houses you know so
i was doing some coke i was eating some
quaaludes and i was drinking
and i went into like i just [__]
passed out guys
and i woke up
and i remember that when i woke up that
time and then people told me the next
day what had happened then when i went
to high school that monday a couple
people pulled me aside and said hey man
we were concerned about it and that was
possibly
when i realized how unhappy i was with
my life like i was trying to kill myself
for my mother's death
i was doing it but i didn't really want
to do it type deal and that scared me
and i said [__] it from now i'm going to
have a little bit more control
i'll only eat two quaaludes instead of
four from now on
and uh
we're still [__] here but
it's amazing how a kid's life has
changed and when i talk about a kid's
life i talk about it all over the
country
but i talk about it here you know when i
used to travel
to different cities every weekend that's
the one thing i would do is you know
drive around and go wow maybe this town
has a neighborhood where kids are
playing no it's not a thing anymore
very seldom do you have even here
around the corner like i said jim's son
he's out there
a couple days a week maybe one day all
the kids come out but it's not how it
was when i was growing up and even over
here i have the neighbors across the
street i got the neighbors around the
corner the kids come out and all of them
meet but it's like a very
weird thing three of them or four of
them will get together but we really
have two
three
five
seven eight kids part of this [__]
little
development where i live and if three of
them or four of them get together it's a
lot every once in a while oh i hate them
around there's actually there's two
other kids too so that counts
[__] ten and again
i don't want my wa my daughter to go out
and die in new jersey you know i'm
already scared of her going down the
shore you know mike i don't have to tell
these people how bad the [__]
that shore is down there with the
undertows and the undercurrent people
always [__] die down the shore
holy [__]
today this podcast is about dying no it
ain't it's about [__] just the
dangers of uh
what it is to be
young and want to have fun man
you know sometimes things are going to
go awry
i look at my life sometimes i'm like
[__] i'm surprised more people didn't
die with the [__] we were doing whether
it was the drugs the bills
the jumping off buildings hitting each
other with light bulbs to [__]
quaaludes
i mean i'm very thankful
you know like when i see what happened
with kate
last year you know how many [__]
times that could have happened to me
you know i'm in houston texas doing a
weekend there's a feature act
and
i go to a party after [__] whatever
and somebody just dies and you're at the
party now you got to give a [__]
statement to the cops
now they call the comedy club the agent
wants to talk to you about it
you have no [__] idea how much murder
i got away with from how lucky i was
that a lot of things could have happened
and i'm looking at it
so analyze your life yeah we had a good
time growing up we jumped out windows we
robbed trains but how [__] lucky are
we really
how [__] lucky you know one of the
things i do every morning
and it's crazy that i've been doing it
for a while you guys
remember when i started by the time we
had
catherine narducci on
it's something that ari told me to start
doing and that's it
go in the shower and say five things
you're grateful for every day you know
and then i did one better
when i get up in the mornings
and i grab that cup of coffee before
anything [__] comes into my head i go
outside it's cold as it is i don't give
a [__] how cold it is
i go outside at eight in the morning and
i sit on my chair outside and get a
little [__]
cold air in my lungs it's good for your
immune system and i try to make eye
contact with the sun i mean i try to
look at the sun i thank god for give me
another day
to be a bad [__] like and i just
i do five things i'm grateful for i'm
grateful for mike
being in my life i'm grateful for my
daughter i'm grateful to god for the
house he gave me i just remind myself
five things every morning and how
[__] weird is it when i got the whoop
watch the woo pack
when you sleep at night you're supposed
to
press a button and tell the what that
you're gonna that's your activity is
sleep
but when you wake up the next morning as
soon as i pee in the morning i brush my
teeth i come out i stop that time
and then i go get coffee i sit outside
when i finish with all that
i come downstairs i plug my phone in
and before that application
for tomorrow could go process to sleep
every morning whoop asks you
a couple questions they ask you uh
you know did you use your sleep apnea
mask did you use did you sleep with a
humidifier
did you have sex last night did you
sleep with somebody on the bed did you
have a cat or an animal in the room when
you slept with you think about this [__]
i've always loved sleeping in my room
with an animal i always think that you
pet them whether it's a dog or a cat
they sleep next to you and it helps you
go to sleep a lot easier it just stops
your [__] day
and ask you if you use the cbd product
and ask if you stretched and asked you
if you were grateful
and that's you a couple [__] really
cool questions
but the questions that i
really couldn't believe and asked me was
did you practice being grateful today
so it kind of like you have to i don't
write down what i'm grateful for i
already say it to the universe every
morning
they ask you you know and i just write i
did write and i'm grateful they ask you
like 12 or 15 questions if you write yes
you have to explain yourself so be
careful what you're right yes or but i
like all that [__] i like it that
it's actually psychologically good to do
that to say every morning what you're
grateful for even if you're in jail even
if you're missing an eye who gives a
[__] there's gotta be there's gotta be
something you're [__] grateful for
even when i was in my darkest [__]
times there was always something i was
grateful for for
so this week you know think about going
out to play and dying but the most
important thing i want you to think
about this week is what you're grateful
for every day because it makes a big
difference in your life i thought arya
was playing tricks on me and [__] the
geniuses that whoop [__] do it so the
geniuses that whoop and do it that means
we gotta [__] do it anyway that's
today's [__] podcast on a
beautiful
monday morning i got my little bob la
lingas double 07 night and i'm ready to
[__] go i love you [__]
thank you very much for listening every
monday morning and getting in [__]
tune with the world
and thank you for always having my
[__] back
you know i love you [__] with all
my heart it's gonna be a great week
and it's up to you to decide what hand
you're gonna sling dick with me
i'm using both [__] hands to
sling with this week i love you have a
great week and i'll see you guys monday
the 23rd tip top magu i think it's
julius irving's birthday i love you
[__] stay black
all right you [__] savages i want to
thank you guys for watching the podcast
or listening or whatever you do and i
want to thank you guys for having my
back but remember one thing everybody
needs help from time to time we get
stuck and the good thing is the joint is
sponsored by better help online therapy
relationships take work a lot of us will
drop anything to go help somebody out
listen
monday mornings i love them because i
invest in myself it's my own personal
therapy plus i thought i talked to dana
over at betterhelp
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you to take care of your
most important relationship and that's
the one you have with yourself like i
said i love mondays i've been working
with betterhelp.com
and they've done wonders by me you guys
can hear it in my voice the way i look
the way i act that's all thanks to
better help you know taking me off the
ledge of my anxiety so whether it's
hitting the gym making time for your
haircut or even trying therapy you are
your greatest asset so invest the time
and effort in yourself like you do with
other people
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and it could be matched with the
therapist in the 48 hours when you need
them give it a try and see why two
million people have used better help
online therapy
the joint is sponsored by better help
and listeners get 10 off the first month
at betterhelp.com
i'm going to help you out with the price
and you're going to get some help for
you to find peace that's betterhelp.com
diaz and not
for the last but i love this product
blue chew
why are you walking around with a half a
dick when you could be stabbing
[__] in a big way with a nice
[__] hard [__]
listen let blue chew throw out that
[__] winter dick i love blue chew
it's easy it's affordable it gets
delivered right the house with no drama
and guess what it works you could take
it any time day or night and the process
is simple sign up at bluetooth.com and
talk to their licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part is it's all online no doctor's
office no pharmacy no judgment it ships
right to your door to discreet package
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
like you like it and it's way cheaper
than any pharmacy
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to sling dick
blue chew can help
do me a favor
they got a special deal for the joint
listeners try blue chew free when you
use promo code joey at checkout just by
fame five dollars for shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code joey to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information i want to thank bluetooth
for sponsoring the joint i also want to
thank honett
betterhelp and lucy.com
thank you very much for listening or for
watching i love you [__] have a
great monday and i'll see you
[__] wednesday the 23rd
tip
top magoo stay black
[Music]
you